hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday December 18th 2017 what's
going on how are you how you doing how I
a look at you over there you look good
you look good I you know a lot of people
probably think I'm in a great mood with
that Patriots victory yesterday which is
actually today because I'm recording at
night but I I just what can they fix
that [ __ ] rule okay that's a it's a
catch
you caught the [ __ ] ball you ran with
the ball you stick it over the goal line
it's a [ __ ] touchdown Dez Bryant few
years ago [ __ ] touchdown the week
before that whoever the [ __ ] Cowboys
played was at the Lions they should have
won that game I I don't I don't [ __ ]
get it I don't understand how that rule
is supposed to make it less confusing
nobody even touched the guy he had
control of the ball I don't like the
ground can't cause a fumble but it can
cause an incomplete pass it can break up
a pass so only if you're a receiver do
you get [ __ ] over by the ground but if
your running back you're in the clear
does that how it works
I'll say that's gonna be the last one
that they're gonna have to adjust it
that rule on during the offseason they
have to fix it because that was for
home-field advantage throughout the
playoffs that was [ __ ] huge and it's a
[ __ ] amazing game amazing [ __ ]
game right I think we both can agree
with that on both sides and by the way
Conte ass [ __ ] Steeler fans remember
I'm saying this [ __ ] for one of the
pendulum swings you're [ __ ] way
alright I hate I hate when [ __ ] some
when I hate those sports fans where if
there's a [ __ ]
call in it goes your way yeah that's
like that 50-year old guy banging an 18
year old girl what legal you know
there's no scumbag eree going on there
yeah that dad I don't know that whole
[ __ ] thing was just like I'm trying
to remember what happened at the end of
the game okay the game starts off great
I know I'm gonna say the guy's [ __ ]
name wrong I've been too [ __ ] busy
but uh seeing Ryan shazier as any sane
shazier you know at the game that was
great to see and he looked like he was
in great spirits and I was looking up
like like I don't know if you guys know
this but like paralysis is a major
[ __ ] like phobia you know like people
go I don't want to be burned to death
like my thing is just [ __ ] laying
there not being able to move I don't
know like that that just seems like the
worst I don't know worse than [ __ ]
death so to see that that guys getting
feeling in his legs and that type of
stuff was I don't know there's some
weird selfish way it was like a relief
to me I probably should have thought of
him first but I'm a selfish [ __ ] living
in Hollywood and that's why the good
Lords burning it down no let this even
me you know you know what it was I
actually felt great for the guy but I
grew up in such a [ __ ] up part of the
world that actually me saying something
nice about him I got I got weirded out
so then I had to be a dick throughout
all of that so anyways what I'm trying
to say is I'm really happy that that guy
looks like he's gonna be okay okay
that's what I was trying to say so it
starts off with that and then it's gonna
be another classic Patriots Steeler
battle which it was we missed an extra
point is that gonna come back to haunt
us there's no way this game could go
into overtime that's what I'm thinking
and then all of a sudden dude the
Steelers hit the [ __ ] game one who's
kidding who and then the last two
possessions before we went with the
go-ahead score they kind of [ __ ]
played a little alligator arm ball right
which allowed us to get back in it then
Brady threw an interception but the guy
dropped it sorry the guy drops the ball
this is what I can remember the dude
dropped the [ __ ] ball that
was the end of the game and then tony
romo gold yet basically what i was
saying we go down the field brady to
grunt brady to grunt brady to grunt
brady to drunk touchdown
two-point conversion brady to grunt go
[ __ ] yourself alright
that was like when Batman and Robin on a
TV show would be stuck in a [ __ ] trap
you know what I mean and they'd we ended
the episode that's that [ __ ] that Caped
Crusader officer they break out and they
beat the [ __ ] out of everybody right
that was the football version of that ok
so then there's 50 something seconds
left and I'm not feeling comfortable
because they got [ __ ] Big Ben and
they have this great field goal kicker
and I know that everybody's gonna go
into the [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] they
went into whatever that defense is that
makes everybody look like Joe Montana
including [ __ ] a Jimmy Garoppolo out
there in San Francisco I love how both
quarterbacks who's the [ __ ] guy in
Tennessee is it Vinny Testaverde is he
still playing Mike Moriarty what the
[ __ ] sake never met his name the kid
from Oregon he marches down the field go
ahead score you know against they're
[ __ ] well it's the end of the game so
now we don't play defense so I guess the
ratings increase is that what happens
right they go ahead and win they'd go
for the go-ahead score then [ __ ]
49ers get the ball back or they just
march right down the goddamn field they
all right there Fred
anyways so it's like 56 seconds left
what the [ __ ] just don't let him get out
of bounds give them the middle of the
field I guess that's what they try to do
and what do we do what the [ __ ] did we
do how many times is our defense going
to do this to Tom Brady after he wins a
[ __ ] game God knows we did it twice
playing the Giants in the Superbowl Tom
terrific as Paul virzi calls him goes
down the [ __ ] field and for the
go-ahead score all that defense has to
do is stop him santé Samuel drops the
[ __ ] ball anyways I don't know what
the [ __ ] let me let me stay on this year
here so I don't know what this [ __ ]
defense is gonna do so for whatever
[ __ ] reason Ben Roethlisberger
[ __ ] throws was it a screen pass that
goes for 69 [ __ ] yards it was like
the guy it was like the obviously turned
in like a third grade Pop Warner team
two guys bump into each other and the
dude continues on down the [ __ ]
sideline now that down at the 10-yard
line and all I'm thinking well the very
least this is going to go into [ __ ]
overtime right Ben goes back to pass
throws it to the [ __ ] was in a white
dude I didn't remember everything
happened so fast he caught the ball he
goes in touchdown right well they're
gonna look to see if his knees down I
can't believe I cannot [ __ ] believe
they called that back what more do you
have to do to establish possession he's
got the ball is he supposed to stop with
ten seconds left and hold it up to the
ref this is a football I have it in my
hands try to run it in the guy did
exactly what the [ __ ] he was supposed to
do he caught the ball headed to the end
zone reached out and scored they took it
away from him then I think the you know
this is when it comes down to coaching
and this is why the Patriots win these
games is that when they [ __ ] called
the [ __ ] touchdown back it didn't
look like the [ __ ] Steelers knew what
they wanted to do I don't know what the
hell that was and I'm just basically
telling you what the [ __ ] you saw I'm G
because I'm doing it Sunday night I
still can't believe that we not even
that we won the game I can't believe
that that wasn't a catch and a touchdown
I don't know what else you have to do to
show possession you know what I'm for
like the 19th time on this [ __ ]
podcast I'm gonna look up this rule and
I'm going to read it
reading NFL rules is it's like reading
the Bible it's like what are they
talking about
all right NFL that's why you have a
preacher for all the dummies out like I
actually do my times I've sat down when
I was younger and I tried to read the
Bible it's like can we can we update
this [ __ ] can we put it in some into
some language that I can understand cuz
it might as well be in Latin I don't
know what anybody's talking about just
know there's a lot of murder and incest
in the beginning it's just like III
don't want to see the end of this movie
alright NFL rule NFL rule catching pass
how many people look completing a catch
okay what in the [ __ ] do you have to do
alright a player who makes a catch may
advance the ball I'm aware of that a
forward pass is it is complete by the
offense are intercepted
intercepted by the defense if a player
who is in bounds number one secures
control of the ball in his hands or arms
prior to the ball touching the ground
which I felt that guy did see the thing
is you have to know what they consider
securing the ball I think it was
supposed to hold it like an infant and
two touches the ground inbounds with
both feet with any part of his body the
others head that was not applicable to
this all right well I mean yeah I guess
it's applicable to every catch if it
wasn't there was no out-of-bounds issue
here's what I'm saying number three
maintains control the ball after a and B
have been fulfilled until he has the
ball long enough to clearly become a
runner
that's another weird thing it's like
he's running while he catches it he's a
runner the whole [ __ ] play what we
mean is running in full possession of
the ball after fulfilling the
requirements of number one and number
two a player has the ball long enough to
become a runner when after his second
foot is on the ground he is capable of
avoiding or warding off impending
contact of an opponent
what if it's a bang-bang play I guess
then it's not a catch well I guess they
call that all the time okay comma
tucking the ball away turning upfield or
taking additional steps so that's what
happens that I think at the goal line is
when you're that close and there's that
little time left you don't have time and
you fall into the ground you don't have
time to tuck the ball away they okay
they have to put something here for this
goal line [ __ ] or four so first down
situations where they have to be able to
understand that somebody is reaching the
ball forward to either get a first down
or a touchdown maybe that's what it is
so I guess because he didn't tuck the
ball away if a player has control of the
ball a slight movement of the ball will
not be considered a loss of possession
he must lose control of the ball in
order to rule that there has been a loss
of possession so he has to establish
control and then lose control if the
player loses the ball while
simultaneously touching both feet or any
part of his body to the ground it's not
a catch
all right so both feet were on the
ground so they thought he lost control
of the ball or never had it to begin
with
despite the fact that he caught it and
then turned upfield for those finals
whatever three yards saw the goal line
took the ball and reached over the
[ __ ] goal line I just feel like for
me when you [ __ ] have the ball and
you're like if he wasn't in control he
wouldn't have done something like that
he wouldn't be going like wow like
[ __ ]
yet that they [ __ ] juggling the
[ __ ] thing
alright end zone catches for the
requirement for a catch in the end zone
are the same as the requirements for a
catch in the field of play note in the
field of play if a catch of a forward
pass has been completed after which
contact by a defender causes the ball to
become loose before the runner is down
by contact
it is a fumble and
the ball remains a life that all makes
sense in the end zone the same action is
a touchdown because the plays
automatically oh okay I understand that
that makes sense
all right four ball touches ground if
the ball touches the ground after the
player secures control of it
it is a catch provided the player
continues to maintain control all right
so they didn't think he secured it or
had control of it so what constitutes
having control of it or securing the
ball jesus [ __ ] christ I mean do you
feel any closer to having an answer for
that
I don't anyways so here's a bright side
if you're a Steeler fan in this weird
way I was kind of hoping the Patriots
we're gonna lose that game even though
we would have to play you guys in
Pittsburgh I just feel like both teams
are so evenly matched that it's gonna be
very hard for one of the two teams to
beat each other twice to sweep the other
team so I was thinking like well if we
lose then Belichick is gonna figure out
what they're [ __ ] doing and then he'll
correct it he's done that time and again
and he'll avenge the loss and God knows
we've gone into Pittsburgh enough time
and won there so we know we can do that
but now I don't know I don't know about
this one I don't know like that was just
a weird it's just a fight it was just a
weird ending to a game okay and in all
of that what's gonna be forgot is that
we gave up 69 yards on a [ __ ] screen
pass at the end of the [ __ ] game and
should have lost but we did so now we're
gonna be home I don't know I don't know
that was uh that was weird that was a
weird one
[Music]
that was just a weird one but thank God
in Pittsburgh they've gone back to back
with Stanley Cups okay so they can
[ __ ] they can stick both those in
their ears so they don't have listened
to dad [ __ ] crying in the other room
I don't know what to tell you guys that
was you know I don't know I am now
fascinated with this I am officially
after this is the third time I've seen a
team get [ __ ] over on a touchdown or
winning the game I have to figure out
what the [ __ ]
when Wendy do you like tucking the ball
away like there's so many times when you
it's like fourth and a couple of yards
where you have to catch and people are
coming in you got to grab it and [ __ ]
reach forward to get a first down I
don't know I have no idea well you know
it's funny on Twitter they were blaming
the Patriots like somehow this is our
[ __ ] you know
Packers you know you could [ __ ] on the
Packers couldn't you didn't they benefit
from that Cowboys benefited and get
[ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know I don't know
somehow I know it will somehow go back
to deflate gate somehow it'll go back to
that [ __ ] once again you know what I
mean I swear to God
anyways plowing ahead I just got back
from Orlando Florida in Fort Lauderdale
Florida two of the most fun shows I had
this year just great crowds I was down
there with Forrest Shaw and it's great
panacek I I'm just not drinking dude so
I'm getting up early I've been
practicing my drums kind of hard to
practice drums now when I uh it's just
like when we edit a lot of the times my
daughter's up and then that the one
window I have to play is like this time
at night right now when she goes to go
to sleep so I can't be a douche so I
don't not playing as much as I would
like to play but I saw I watched two
amazing documentaries on Netflix I was
embarrassed by my I'll show you know
do you guys know like on your Netflix
homepage like everybody's homepage is
different because they sort of watch
what you watch they have like this
[ __ ] thing and then like whatever
you're into you know what I mean you
guys why am I gonna explain to you
people how it works you know how it
[ __ ] works so everybody's is
different so what mine became was
everything that I was watching see now
it's cool again but what it was before
was everything was just [ __ ] drug
cartels behind the scene prison [ __ ]
what else did they had it was all just
yeah it was just all [ __ ] like that
and then yeah it was just all prisons
drug dealers people getting killed all
of this [ __ ] so I watched two [ __ ]
documentaries like guys I got I got I
gotta watch some other [ __ ] to to switch
this up a little bit and I watch the
John Coltrane documentary and then I
watched one called
I called him Morgan which was about this
trumpet player that I'd never heard of
before called leap guy's name was Lee
Morgan and I cannot tell you how great a
player the guy is and it's an amazing
documentary really sad too but but since
I did that I watched two things with
black people in it I now have a thing
Nat King Cole they got she's got to have
it up here something about Richard Pryor
but I also got better call Saul you know
what I mean there's a way to do this cuz
you're gonna miss all this other cool
[ __ ] if you just keep going down the
rabbit hole watching the same [ __ ] I got
a jimi hendrix thing I got the Jerry
Seinfeld comedian I got one of the Star
Wars movies something about Mike Tyson
right I think it's funny they got that
whole something around Jaco Pastorius
funny he say his [ __ ] name World War
two in color right there you go
no more prison [ __ ] this is great
perfect
all fiction I like it now what's going
too far the other the other direction
like oh this is all this guy wants to
see because I watched this thing they
were like you know before never seen
behind the scenes in a Russian prison
and they were showing these guys and as
bad as the prison was what's great about
it was is if you commit a bad enough
crime you don't have to worry about
getting raped yes they don't leave you
alone
there's staring at you 24 [ __ ] 7 it's
I didn't watch it that long enough all I
know was the crimes these guys committed
were so [ __ ] horrific and then they
cut to the the the warden and he goes I
have no sympathy for these people
whatsoever and I was just like yeah
neither do I this guy killed the whole
family and then like took that bodies
out in the woods and [ __ ] lit him on
fire and it's just like yeah yeah [ __ ]
that guy I think I sitting there going
you know you got to be really strong
mentally here or you're not gonna make
it it's just like III hope you don't
yeah so I watched 10 minutes of it and I
agreed with the warden and I shut it off
and then I just looked at my page at
that point and that's all it was but
anyways I got to tell you that Lee
Morgan was a guy I believe who did he
start out with I watched so much [ __ ]
this weekend the [ __ ] did he start out
with he start out with felonious monk I
can't remember he played a little bit
with John Coltrane and then he got into
with Art Blakey the Jazz Messengers and
then he went out on his own but like his
playing is just he sees one of the guys
you know what I mean I don't know like
you know like guitar players there's a
bunch of guys that can [ __ ] shred and
then there's the guy that makes you
[ __ ] hair stand up on your arm like
that guys one of the guys he's that with
the trumpet the name of the thing is
called I called him Morgan I figured
what the John Coltrane was but the
Coltrane one was on a whole other level
where it actually makes you want to be a
better person that's the only way to
describe it his [ __ ] worldview was
incredible and I didn't I didn't know a
lot about him you know I'm the typical
John Coltrane hockey fan like I have a
Love Supreme
you know but I should get all those
other ones blue train and all that type
of stuff but I always went down the
Miles Davis road like wherever he went
whoever he played with I just kind of
followed all the way through that and I
know Coltrane was was with them twice he
had fired one time in the second time he
left and so then I just followed miles
into his second was a quartet of quintet
and quintet and that's the one with Tony
Williams and then I just stayed with
Tony right through lifetime and all the
[ __ ] he was doing and I kind of missed
all those other guys so I'm finally
going back and listening to all these
guys and that that [ __ ] music is
incredible it's [ __ ] incredible and
the way they shoot it and the
black-and-white when you see the video
and stuff it's unbelievable and there's
this weird thing where you wouldn't
think with jazz is like a danger to it
but there's like a [ __ ] edge to it
that is uh I don't know it's compelling
and I just I wish they had more
documentaries like that on on Netflix so
if people know some other streaming
service or some [ __ ] where I can watch
it because I would watch about anybody
from that and then I end up finding out
by like Shelley is it Shelley man a
Shelley man he's like a famous jazz
drummer a white dude and through
watching a Coltrane thing I saw they
played a gig and he had this this
Shelley man had this place called
Shelley man's man hole as Shelley's man
hole or something like that and I was
sitting there going like I wonder where
that it that that was in LA cuz nothing
has ever preserved in LA and I found out
that it's right on Cahuenga
just north of Sunset right around the
corner from big Wang's where I used to
go there all the time before I was
married and watch games and all that
[ __ ] I just was thinking like Miles
Davis John Coltrane all these monster
[ __ ] players
all played live right around the corner
for where me and my friends were like
fifty years later going like like how
much that block dropped off but a very
uh Nell a thing I guess there's some
sort of commemorative thing to that jazz
club in the sidewalk there like not like
a star or anything but I thought that
was pretty cool
so anyways alright so there's that check
out both those documentaries if you're
into that type of [ __ ] I know I'm all
over the map here little music little
sports maybe I'm a little uh maybe this
is a nice little [ __ ] balance here
for once alright I do have some sad news
here and this really is sad news I lost
another advertiser now if you're a fan
of the podcast you know this [ __ ]
happens all the [ __ ] time to me
alright there's there's people that you
know they don't quite appreciate that my
colorful way that I try to sell the
products but these people they hung in
there for a long time and they finally
had enough of me and I just want to
thank him for being on the podcast I had
a great time reading their their copy
farewell to sharise berries evidently I
finally went too far weren't I somehow
made a clan reference while reading
about chocolate-covered strawberries I
thought it was funny you know I was with
Harris standing he you know I guess if I
was by myself and I made the Klan
reference it would seem weird but I was
in the room with another black guy not
another black guy with the black guy
right another guy who was black that's
how I was trying to say right so then
obviously well doesn't that obviously
mean that I'm just [ __ ] around I
don't know I had a great time reading
your [ __ ] you have definitely welcome
back any time any time he'd like to come
back we'd love to have you back I love
reading your copy you [ __ ]
strawberries are delicious but I get it
you know what I mean it's a very
sensitive time out there we have we have
to really be conscious of what we're
affiliated with there
I've repaired the Grand Dragon starts
[ __ ] ordering some goddamn
strawberries I don't know I don't know
what people in advertising are you know
what their problem is is they're trying
to please everybody you know and if they
were just collectively if they could
just grow a dick in some [ __ ] balls
and just be happy with selling
strawberries or nature's box or whatever
the [ __ ] it is your blue your blue apron
and all these people who [ __ ] walked
off this podcast if you would just focus
on the front all the money that you you
know do you know what I would be like if
I tried to make everybody laugh yeah I
wouldn't I would have a puppet I don't
know what I would have I would I would I
would I would work totally clean I way I
would not saying any having a puppets
bad not saying working clean is bad but
I would just I would stop you step what
happens is what happens is basically you
step outside yourself and then you start
watching yourself thinking what did they
want and then the second you do that
[ __ ] you've done all right so Sherry's
berries I think you're making a terrible
mistake here you know but I'm letting
you know the door is always open I'll
let you back in like a battered wife you
know in a bad [ __ ] relationship I'll
let you back in and then he can try to
[ __ ] you know what's funny about these
advertisers they always want to talk to
me and there's the rule on the podcast
is I don't talk to any of them okay I'm
not talking to you this this is just
some [ __ ] I do to make people
[ __ ] laughing to promote my gigs okay
I'm not gonna start having [ __ ]
conference calls about chocolate covered
fruit there's only so many hours in the
day you know anyways Happy Trails guys
all right I'll still lower your
strawberries no hard feelings all right
okay man crate everybody man right oh
you know what these sons of guns they
send me there's like these sons of
[ __ ]
I said Sons of Guns cuz I was [ __ ]
thinking about oh oh oh don't [ __ ] don't
don't offend the strawberry people man
crates
these sons of [ __ ] sent me they sent
me a bunch of booze
they sent me all this cool grill stuff
it actually comes in a crate you feel
like a man when you open it up it's
fantastic I can't wreck I can't
recommend this enough now I'm not saying
that I'm not gonna make the Klan
reference or anything like that when I'm
selling this stuff oh look who's here
look who's here was I too loud just
closer to close the door the whole way
you gonna call though who's the
decorator all right come on in Kimmie
come here do you know do you know do you
know no more sharise berries I know you
burned that bridge I mean I didn't burn
the bridge it was a [ __ ] bridge was
on fire when they got there I did the I
did the bad boy I'm not saying it like
that I'm saying like what I meant by
that you know it's such an [ __ ] why
did I marry you what why did I marry you
I always know when you're full of [ __ ]
yeah what I meant was I was already
doing this [ __ ] when they got with me
[Music]
this this is this is right here
dangerous comic you never know is gonna
come out of your mouth whoo what's he
gonna say now he's so edgy controversial
I'm not you are not you love it you love
being like the outlier of the whole
thing don't you
you love it admit it no I just know what
I'm doing yeah I know what I'm doing I'm
[ __ ] reading advertising and people
don't want to hear it so you doesn't
stop you just keep [ __ ] around at
these [ __ ] dopes who sold [ __ ]
understood that for two seconds
everybody all these other [ __ ]
podcast you know what they do they press
fast-forward they blow right through it
[Music]
it [ __ ] works yeah it's a little late
for that
now that you trash me you dress me down
yeah well you'll be okay what are you
doing here we're on the podcast I can't
listen to her crying that's the hardest
thing is when you set up down there
totally fun they're just crying and
they're trying to get you to pick them
up and you can't [ __ ] do it
anyways alright we ready here now that
you [ __ ] dress me down here okay now
you want Nia I will read this copy
straight I can't I can totally do it you
want to bet you can do it I just wasn't
trying to be like that but go ahead do
it okay man crates it's hard to pick out
the perfect gift but all too easy to get
it totally wrong I like to think the
fear right out of the bat rather bat no
curse beads of sweat forming on your
forehead oh my god get me a crate
somehow solve this yeah I can't do it
this is how I watch TV I it's
interactive introducing then they sent
me all this cool [ __ ] introducing man
crate calm the surest way to find
awesome gift gifts guys will love
guaranteed this isn't a lame cheese of
the Month Club or a new tie man okay man
crate offers awesome gifts for every
type of man from the rugged outdoorsman
to this sports fanatic and everything in
between I'm sorry that's a small window
if you gotta go rugged outdoorsman you
you should only two types of guys well
no they did say everything in between
but those are the two the two ends well
I guess if you go hunting if you go
hunting you don't really watch football
D I don't know I don't do either those
things what animal could you shoot what
animals do you eat oh I eat all of them
I mean I eat the ones that you can eat
so you're sort of like a Mafia don just
having everybody do all your hits for
you only animals that I can kill our
insects and I would kill a possum you
know a lot of work parts of the world's
they eat insects yeah it's a source of
protein I kill them I could eat yeah you
somebody else is around the world going
that's a nice little jalapeno popper
spider there that you can [ __ ] read it
in deep fried awesome cuz that's my
least favorite animal I could also kill
a raccoon cuz I also don't like them you
don't like varmints like varmints no I
know you like a black you said to me Sam
with a [ __ ] who you you're a female
black you said to me Sam you know
remember you little varmint remember
that his [ __ ] red moustache should be
flying around card soon hmm
yeah can you finish this advertising
like the whiskey whiskey appreciation
crate but they personalized laser-etched
decanter and glasses for his favorite
drink and the grillmaster crepe with a
brass knuckle meat tenderizer in a
cast-iron smokebox
smoker box it's a funny word smoker box
say it three times fast
wait what is smoker box smoker box
smoking hot smoker box oh you did it
good just go to man crate comm pick up
the perfect crate choose your delivery
date when his man create arrives he'll
be the envy it's picture some guys
scratching his balls
he'll be the envy of every guy in the
room as he pries open the bad boy with
the no opening with his own laser
engraved crowbar they have thousands of
five-star reviews and every man crate
comes with their high five guarantee up
on the holidays go man crates calm slide
and that's why they listen / / to get
five percent off your order they don't
offer this discount anywhere else that's
five percent off man crates calm / / man
crates calm / / they give you a crowbar
a personalized crowbar
yeah like the kind of crowbar that you
like break into a car with that's why
would you do that
isn't that what auto thieves use
crowbars mmm how would you know that I
wouldn't I'm just from the movies what
movies crowbars do you break into cars
when I'm on the road no but isn't that a
thing that you use a crowbar to like
Jimmy the ha oh boy yeah you take the
crowbar and you slide it in between the
door in the window yeah yeah you just
sort of just sort of slip that in there
do you know what a crowbar looks like um
is there like a wrench like a big it's
you can't that's not what they use I
don't want to fat shame a crowbar but it
cannot fit it cannot fit in that little
area that you have that little this
looked a little slim yeah no that's what
do they call it thing is a slim jim a
little [ __ ] thing you just go down
and they just [ __ ] in there's always
it it looks like he's jerking off was a
crowbar used for it's used to open man
crates in regular crates - what about
lady crates I don't know what they're
you yes probably vibrates - the crew oh
sorry alright Dollar Shave Club jolly
Shave Club Joe what you might not know
is that Dollar Shave Club also has
products for pretty much everything you
need in the bathroom body wash shampoo
hair gel lip balm everything at this
still they're too many you know what out
of respect for Pittsburgh Steeler fans
I'm not gonna read this in a Boston
accent sorry at the store there are too
many options and you can't tell the
difference between any of them then if
you have any questions to cure the Clark
usually doesn't know the difference
either or either can't help you since
they're not experts on the products or
they're the only person working on the
[ __ ] floor
for a limited time Dollar Shave Club is
basically giving away their [ __ ] shower
shave starter set to new members for
only $5 to start a set features the
executive razor and the three trial
versions of their most popular products
that help you stay fresh and clean so if
your first box in your first box you
will see receive their shave fun
body wash in one wipe show
but wipes you also receive their
executive razor which includes their
premium weighty handle and focus set of
cartridges after the first box
replacement cartridges are sent for only
a few bucks a month this offer is
exclusively available at
dollarshaveclub.com Seibert that's
Dulles shave club comm slash bar and if
you want a great gift give them a Dollar
Shave Club give them Dollar Shave Club
no sorry they've got a super single gift
memberships and eat gift cards Dollar
Shave club's high quality products will
have you covered from face cheeks to
butt cheeks there is no better time to
try the club and lastly but not leastly
simply safe if you've been thinking
about your home security there's no
better time to get it than right now
simply safe has put together a massive
security arsenal for your home a special
package hand-picked just for you it's
got entry sensors motion sensors and
glass break sensors everything you need
to stop criminals from ever touching
your goddamn home and right now for the
holidays our friends at simply safe are
giving you an absolutely incredible
offer get two security package it comes
it's complete protection for your home
simply sleep it's already the best value
in home security there's no contracts no
commitments but right now get $200 off
this holiday special security package
just go do thinpla faith bird calm
that's simply safe bird calm to take
advantage of this holiday offer and save
$200 on your simply safe home security
system simply safe bird comm how many
[ __ ] times all right there you go see
Mia wasn't that enjoyable was it
dangerous that I seemed like I was
trying to get a danger award there and
now I'm just being silly okay he could
be so mean sometimes um hey I'm on tray
number three tray number three um oven
visit douche operation and visit do show
my teeth are starting to move I have a
couple announcements Patrice O'Neal if
you want to egg you guys want a great a
great gift idea
Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit get two
tickets for the person you love stuff at
their goddamn stocking and come out and
see the show on February 20th at the New
York City Center in Manhattan if you
don't live in Manhattan it's a great
excuse to come to New York City and
check it out before the entire thing
becomes a giant Bed Bath & Beyond all
right well what am i up to here third in
that 40 minutes all right can you help
me out here Neal with the she's sleeping
right was she doing looks like she is
she's still squirming all right Oh also
Santa Steve Steve Simone the great Steve
motif Simone and regular hero are
raising money again this year for
children fighting cancer and their
families
Monday morning podcast listeners helped
raise $15,000 last time around and it
had a huge impact on a lot of families
their stories are brutal and every bit
helps the goal this year's 50 grand will
tweet a link today thank you guys so
much
you've already been ridiculously
generous this year so thank you very
much all right
mp3 player all right yeah you're gonna
be in an onion on this here you're gonna
help me out here yeah okay
you don't sound too enthused would you
like your own microphone I think it'd be
better if you had your own microphone
talk to bill is wearing a pair of
pajamas that I got him for Christmas not
last year but maybe the year before was
it last year a pair of pajamas that had
got him last year and he looks like like
he's in that show my two dads that I
like more my three sons doo doo doo doo
no my two dads was a porno wasn't no it
was an eighty show about dads for a
reason that I can't really recall for
the situation comedy of it maybe her mom
died
her mom wasn't sure which one was her
dad so they were both her dad or maybe
she was dating one but the other one was
her dad I don't really know but it was
my two dads and I used to watch it
sounds like the jizz was flying around
all right
mp3 player I know what do you want me
for me mp3 player hey Billy red face
Merry Christmas dude
thank you my suggestion Merry Christmas
to you too my suggestion for mp3 player
is the Apple watch I'm trying to get out
I'm trying to get out of them I'm trying
to get away from Apple okay because I
have all this other music and they just
won't recognize it and I'd buy it off of
him but they don't have it all right
whatever I'll listen to you I know it's
more than an mp3 player but that's the
great thing is you get so much more for
the money
the big drawback is that you can only
use bluetooth headphones with it that's
the thing about app and let me guess
only bluetooth headphones made by
[ __ ] Apple other than that I like
that it stays strapped to your wrist so
you don't need to carry anything else
with you if you've got the series three
with the elf this sounds like a giant
commercial for this thing but I you know
I did ask the series three with LTE it
doubles as a phone so what do you talk
to your wrist like [ __ ] Captain Kirk
the call time is very limited I'm not
doing this why would I do this
I'm apps okay friend who smells like
anus oh boy hey you redheaded mcmaster
die and I'll give a [ __ ] what are you
gonna do I don't what about that thing I
told you what do you think about that
where you know Matt Damon commented on
that's the the stuff going on in
Hollywood so this person wrote an
article about him and they go Matt Damon
a white male blah blah blah blah blah
like it was just like who doesn't know
he's a white guy like what does that
mean his big white trap is that not
race-baiting that's like some FoxNews
[ __ ] there was no reason to say what his
race was or his sex was there
the person there was nothing anything
else they just said that he was a white
male and then they just continued on
with the [ __ ] thing
it's [ __ ] this is such a it's I swear
to God watching I don't know it's just I
don't get if you're just gonna if you
just just say listen on now I'm now it's
my turn to be a douche then I'm fine
with it but don't [ __ ] act like
you're a better person because you're
not I mean that's that's a [ __ ] I mean
you keep what you're looking at me like
that you can't you can't [ __ ] go to
wrongs don't make a right
nothing what do you mean two wrongs
don't make that's total that's [ __ ]
race-baiting all stereotypes about
[ __ ] with this whole thing about
sexual harassment just saying that
someone's a white male how was that
raised baiting this is so funny I sound
like a black person right now and you
sound like a white person what all we
said was says he was just white I don't
understand what you mean
call somebody what they are a white male
oh you're saying that if this was like
Fox News they'd know this is know this
is what they were doing Jackson black
male was spotted at the bubble I like
the way they do I'm saying the reason
that they added that detail was because
he was commenting on sexual harassment
and white guys positions of power and
all of that so what they were saying in
there is they just say white males so
then you can go with all your
stereotypes and be like Oh totally
privileged didn't have to work for [ __ ]
in a position of power he doesn't
understand this like all this negative
[ __ ] where it was no longer Matt Damon
it was hashtag white male trash that's
what the [ __ ] guy was doing a woman
whoever wrote that [ __ ] article
that's what bugged me whether you agreed
with what he said or not is a completely
different thing but I just suppose like
what the [ __ ] does anything what the
[ __ ] doesn't know Matt Damon's a white
guy no he's just some [ __ ] they had a
[ __ ] picture of him anyways if he was
some complete nobody I see the picture
it was a giant picture of Matt Damon's
white head
and they go Matt Damon a white male you
know what they're doing that's that
feminist [ __ ] psycho [ __ ] that
[ __ ] psycho [ __ ] white male trash all
that [ __ ] that they're doing that
literally doing this not not saying all
of them are doing it but they're doing
that [ __ ] where they're there they're
fighting this thing that they are
literally becoming no no no no keep it
up I'm not talking about what he said
I'm talking about that [ __ ] detail
was [ __ ] weird
just throw in there my team and , Matt
Damon white male it's like male
prostitute was like what the [ __ ] does
that have to do with anything and then I
read the art that gist of the article
like oh oh I see why you threw that in
there he's speaking like a typical white
guy so yeah Wow look at that
look who's always getting thrown around
well why you Mia you know how they are
you know how those white guys are where
you feel like I'm secret by I see really
hey people no no no I'm just I'm
actually you know in a way enjoying this
[ __ ] because of all that hey white guys
are evil and blah blah blah and I just
note that human beings who have too much
[ __ ] power I would agree with that
and when you have too much power as a
nation or as a [ __ ] race or a sex you
stand you tend to it's very hard to not
overstep your bounds okay and what I am
now seeing is the pendulum is changing
is that people that what I always felt
is people just gonna behave the same way
it's not going to become better it's
just somebody else will then get in
power and then behave the exact same
[ __ ] way
while they pat them on selves on the
back saying how great they are like
white guys who did a bunch of horrific
[ __ ] and then put up statues of
themselves does that make sense
interesting point ooh ouch alright
friend who smells like anus wench come
over here
yeah what's that what's uh what's
a-happening hot stuff that's racist
did the Dollar Shave Club not I don't
know I just it's funny I've heard that
name my whole life I don't even know who
that is then you get stuck on an island
or was he like a we got to look it up
now there you go there's your quote for
the week everybody it's something from
literature that's what I married and
made a child with it's something from
literature Robinson Caruso a white man
I'd go with all of it I did big argument
somebody about that about the whole
Judas you can't discover some [ __ ] when
people are already there and this guy
actually argue with me he goes well he
was discovering it for himself and the
people didn't know but it's just like
Columbus I forget who he was talking
about [ __ ] that guy if he didn't coming
out you you wouldn't I met me wow really
listen yeah you know to make an omelet
you got to break a few eggs Oh [ __ ]
dip
Neah adults listen to this they know I'm
[ __ ] around jesus [ __ ] christ
the cuts out they will take that clip
and watch will see the trouble I get
that's that's a classic one for
Huffington Post [ __ ] douchebags those
low hanging fruit douchebags
alright Robinson Caruso Robinson Crusoe
everyone says Robinson Caruso but it
looks like Crusoe I say Caruso because I
always think of Rick Carruth first
published on the 25th of April 1719 the
first editions blah blah
plot summary Jesus get to the cliffnotes
this is too long Crusoe
but he was shipwrecked know about that
did they do a second version where that
wasn't in there no they make it they
make him out like he's some [ __ ] hero
though don't they
cannibals discover NER cannibals and
island kill and he prisoner it's for his
arrival there only only he and three
animals the captain's dog and two cats
survived the shipwreck overcoming his
despair he fetches arms tools and
supplies so basically white people read
this ignore the slavery part and then
root for this white guy to come home
because they put themselves in that
place how did we get on the subject of
that guy all you said my beard alright
well the three months were the three
musketeers Christopher Columbus Matt
Damon white males was it wasn't a why do
they need to shut the [ __ ] up that's
such an ignorant statement it isn't here
you can't want if you tell people to
shut the [ __ ] up and they're not gonna
listen to your point that like what you
just said there is how people try and
communicate in the Internet well they
start things off with hey [ __ ] dick
maybe if you [ __ ] didn't have your
head up your ass and they could actually
be making a good point but they started
that way if you tell people that they
need to shut the [ __ ] up and then what
listen to you what what sort of human
being is gonna be receptive to what you
have to say if that's the way you're
going to get dipping into the pool that
is because I'm thinking about other
things I'm Matt Damon has said other
like Sir Stan's is that he's taken and I
just feel like he
is really arrogant and he's not really
as worldly and understands people as
well as he thinks that he does and he's
in a very like small little bubble and
I'm just I'm not here you've never met
this guy and I guarantee if you went to
a Christmas party out there and he was
there you'd be like oh my god Matt
Damon's here maybe a couple years ago I
would oh Jesus Christ
everybody needs to just [ __ ] just
just just relax a little bit look first
of all this wasn't even about that this
wasn't even about what the [ __ ] he said
what it was about was that that [ __ ]
person says Matt Damon white male a
white male I'm just saying that's all
I'm talking about I don't give a [ __ ]
about all of that other [ __ ] I'm trying
to stay out of that [ __ ] but I'm trying
to say project greenlight and the last
season and the way all right okay dan
what are you doing
geez he's already getting enough [ __ ]
[ __ ] him throw more crap on the fire
me no that's not what I'm saying
I'm not trying it's such you are such an
[ __ ] on this why did I invite you in
that's not why I'm saying that now you
made me look like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's not the point is first of all Nia
he's that but this is the thing this is
the thing that every dumb mistake people
think if you get to know the actor
they're gonna get you in the movie
they're not they're not that's not how
that works they're trying to keep their
own [ __ ] a head above water they
don't have [ __ ] time for you and can
i play your [ __ ] postman they don't
give a [ __ ]
all right jesus [ __ ] christ I gotta
tell you you're killing it on this
podcast because every time I try to make
a [ __ ] point you trash me in such a
way that it just destroys anything I'm
trying to say I'm just saying I'm just
you know Jesus Christ I can't look I
can't make fun of the Huffington Post
and then get somebody else in trouble
for some
[ __ ] they already got in trouble for
that's that's what I'm saying I'm
leaving it alone okay I'm leaving [ __ ]
alright friend who smells like anus for
the 90th [ __ ] time I'll tell you I
think you're banned from this podcast
huh yeah go ahead you read it thank you
big fan of the podcast my friend and I
saw you and miss stuff don't forget this
part you already read that hey you
redheaded Macbeth stirred
that's offensive now somebody's gonna
take that something's gonna take that
and cut out the part where you said
that's offensive
I just wanted you on tape saying hey you
redheaded make faster and I love it
alright big fan of the podcast my friend
and I saw you and mr. versi do stand-up
in Albany New York phenomenal show my
question is about women's hygiene humbly
my two buddies and I have a friend that
is a very nice person and he was very
preppy clothing however however she
smells like a bag of rotten clams the
odor has become so bad that the three of
us have questioned whether wearing a gas
about question whether wearing a gas
mask around her this person needs to
write better as men we know it is not
right to tell a woman she smells like
ass but we don't know what else to do
should we tell her or call one of her
friends into telling her a thanks bill
keep up the hilarious podcast and go
[ __ ] yourself first of all you are so
unoriginal by being like she smells like
a bag of rotten clams you know clams
[ __ ] second of all if you're not
[ __ ] this broad no you don't have
anything to say next all right Nia got a
little defensive Nia can I ask you a
question if you walked around smelling
like a bag of rotten clams wouldn't you
want somebody to give you the heads up
before you became a very preppy clothing
however she smells like what does that
have to do with it I don't
get it Oh cuz she's nice and she wears
nice clothes but she smells like clams a
bag of rotten clamps a bag of rotten
clams this sounds like an exaggeration
give me a break
smell so bad the three of us have
questioned whether wearing a gas why are
you.why around or what like where's the
rest of your sentence first of all learn
how to write a sentence properly then
maybe I can why are you getting so
defensive like they said you smell like
a bag of rotten clams
this is this [ __ ] thing you're just
defending this person because she's a
wiener you inserted yourself in the
story and you would be the person put
myself in the scenario I guess so so now
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
help pull you out of that and say that
you in no way shape shape or form smell
like a bag of rotten clamps
how can they tell her all right this
this this woman okay probably wants to
find love at some point and you're not
gonna you're really limiting you know
she's got to find somebody that works in
some sort of chemical plant that's
destroyed his sense of smell yeah
sometimes you could have like literally
a sinus infection that can give you a
really bad breath there's all kinds of
stuff like you know and this is a thing
like guys like it's not like I never ran
into a woman that didn't wasn't so fresh
and so clean you know and I there's no
way to tell him because it the
embarrassment of it what should I do
singing telegram how can they do that I
would actually I would I would actually
think that she needs if she's dressing
nice and all that type of stuff meaning
she's clean I would say that she
probably needs to see a doctor and it's
probably something with her diet I'm
just this is just [ __ ] that I've heard
diet I don't know
maybe she's stressing a lot I have no
idea but well how would you handle it
okay if they it's like the end of a Tom
Cruise movie and you got to clip the
right [ __ ] wire it blows up in your
face okay
first first thought are you doing it I
think you you take you take them out not
on like a date but just hang out and
just be like listen I love you so much
you are such an amazing person you are
the best you're the best you're breaking
up with me no no I just feel like you
know sometimes I just noticed like like
an odor coming from you so I don't know
I don't know if I don't know your
washing machine isn't working you know
or like why would she put her vagina in
a washing machine they're not smelling
her vagina they're smelling her Bo right
well when I heard clams I thought the
problem was in the basement acally
exactly they're talking about her Bo I
would assume but we could be halitosis
it could be you're not if you're not
[ __ ] her like what are you what do
you care
you know but because they like her they
want to hang out with them but she
smells like [ __ ] and I'm sorry he
said it bag of clams I don't know what
to tell you yeah she smells like low
tide you should try a different I know
what I would do I get to those spray
aerosol cans of like deodorant and I
dress like a cowboy and I walk into the
barn go hands up and when she did it go
sorry I got nothing I don't know I would
try to have I would I would have I would
talk to a female friend of hers and tell
her to do it because it'll be less
embarrassing and just say you're just
giving it a heads up that's not a friend
and I still have this friend and we had
someone that we worked with someone who
I'm actually still friends with and was
it a white male
yeah and he would talk about how my
friends breath stank and I would always
like laugh because he was right her
breath did stink a lot and I would
always offer her gum gum mints oh you
want one you want one and she would
always refuse so it's like what can I do
you have to sit her now and say [ __ ] yo
[ __ ] think anymore but at the time
there's probably somebody told her all
right dad cheating on mom dear Billy
skank Elsa please do not say my name
we've got a jokey name he's got a jokey
name why he's such a drag all of a
sudden one [ __ ] stinky clam thing and
now come on man lighten up I should be
in a bad mood the way you've been
trashing me on this I invite you want
him onto my show I already lost sharise
berries they're walking out of my life
and then I gotta listen to you trash all
right I have been a fan of yours since
the year 2000 remember that bit how
great was that bit I [ __ ] love that
bit Conan O'Brien show everybody I love
hearing your podcast every week I use it
as it as a escape as an escape from my
shitty life I want to ask you for your
advice about a month ago I started to
notice my father would talk to a
co-worker who happens to be a lady I
didn't think much much of it seeing as
how he's been happily married for the
past 27 years I checked my dad's phone
number my phone the other day he usually
has me fix his phone since he doesn't
understand technology upon checking his
phone I saw a couple of texts and a
picture that they have been sending each
other
all right a couple of texts I don't know
what it was in the text and I know what
the picture was yeah I don't know what
to do I have looked up this guy for 25
years oh no and now I feel crushed
seeing the piece of [ __ ] he is should I
confront him and tell him to stop or
else I'll tell my mother bill can you
please help me thank you and go [ __ ]
yourself from Adolf Stalin what would
you do you had to give your lap' freedom
what will you do I don't know what I
would do I would I would your phone the
other day and I saw this picture of this
woman who is she I would do it there you
go
he'd probably lie just know that he's
probably going to lie to you I mean you
can confront him and just say hey like
well sky was you know you had me fix
your phone I saw these pictures and
these texts like what's going on he's
probably gonna get upset why are you
reading my title I didn't ask you to do
that I just asked you to get me on
airplane mode or whatever [ __ ] it
he did you know why are you looking
right he's probably gonna get really
really upset with you and he's gonna lie
and he's gonna deny it and then he's
gonna be probably overly sweet to your
mom in front of you I don't know but
your um look this guy for 25 years now
yeah it's a hard thing to realize that
your parents are not as perfect and
great and upstanding as you thought they
were not sucks so what do you think you
should just go up and ask them
I mean if it's right yeah he should just
say like hey I just saw these pictures
like you know I don't know what they
were but it I thought they were maybe
something inappropriate but maybe I'm
wrong and it's just been bothering me
but like I said just maybe that'll make
him stop be prepared that he is going to
get very pissed at you you might know
he might be [ __ ] embarrassed I don't
know and it's probably gonna make him be
really upset and yell at him so but I
feel bad for your mom that's the thing
but who knows maybe your parents have an
arrangement that you don't know about oh
Jesus I don't know you gotta consider
all the possibilities here you know but
unless his mom is at home just baking
cookies and making dinner every night
you know and being like if she's just
nagging him every night he just gets
sick of it
maybe she's banging in the mailman hey
you know can we have a little sympathy
for the guy who [ __ ] wrote in here
Jesus Christ I would go with her first
advice all right over okay overrated
underrated is back all right
overrated outdoor hockey games I've been
twice one at Comerica Park in Detroit
and another at the big house it's cold
you can't see the whole ice and it's
hard to track the puck not to mention
the blinding glare from the Sun do
yourself a favor save your money and
watch it at home Wow
underrated homemade french fries if
you're hosting a barbecue or just making
burgers for the family take the time and
make some hand-cut fries double fry them
and toss in sea salt oh if you're
feeling really ambitious a homemade
spicy ketchup will put it over the top
nice your Grand Rapids show at the
church was great can't wait to hear
those jokes again in your next special I
love that [ __ ] that's that's a great
kick all right advice for a lady is this
the last one it's a long one
brace yourselves Bill's gonna be reading
for a while 22 year-old married to a 47
year old oh boy all right I have been
putting off emailing you this because I
feel pretty embarrassed but I adore your
podcast your honest advice and I have
massive amounts of respect for you so
[ __ ] it if you do actually read this or
take the time to respond then thank you
so much
I don't know why but I actually love
when somebody uses the word adore I
adore your podcast it seems so much more
sincere than I love your podcast but now
that I put that out there everyone's
gonna make fun of me and sandwich they
adore I should probably start by saying
that I was in a really bad spot when I
first met my guy I was 20 and he was 45
I lost my mom when I was 17 to lung
cancer and then I lost the mother figure
who had taken me in and I had stayed
with for two years again to lung cancer
Jesus Christ I never knew my dad
you knew that was coming so I know
there's some daddy issues in to play
here probably but anyways I felt like a
giant curse two of my family members
became ill and I was falling behind in
my degree the only happiness I had was
going to concerts getting high and
trying to forget my grief in the music
yeah that sounds like what I would have
done that was until I met my guy at one
of the shows and everything started
changing for the better he had the most
amazing confident positive energy I had
ever seen and I felt so unbelievably
happy just by being around him we
started dating I fell in love hard and
fast forward nine months later we got
married in a Vegas in Vegas on a trip
visiting his family as he's American I
was drunk the marriage is not registered
in the UK and my family still doesn't
know please don't judge me I would never
judge you I'm a [ __ ] mess everything
is mostly wonderful between us and we
have lived together for a year now he's
a roadie and we'll typically spend a
couple of months touring and then three
months at home in that cycle he is 100%
trustworthy
I like that dynamic we have because I
get my own time to focus on my freelance
work but the time apart keeps the love
fresh and exciting especially as we
travel a lot when he is off to work but
he wants to start breeding within a
couple years in whilst he is someone I
would start a family with I know I'm not
ready for anything like that
we've spoken about this and he said he
would wait a few years but I still know
I'm not gonna be ready in a few years I
still feel like a lost teenager most of
the time I know what the
responsibilities so I know what the
responsible thing to do is which is to
end it but he's been the reason the last
couple years of my life have been so
much brighter and happier than they have
and so long he's great in bed super
thoughtful and generous no it isn't a
sugar daddy thing but it's nice having
someone want to look after you
I just don't know what to do at all I
really don't want to lose him but he's
47 now and wants kids as soon as
possible I don't want to be a [ __ ] and
knowingly waste his time I do have a
good jaysus okay two more progress I do
have a good circle of friends that I'll
be absolutely fine alone slash single
but I just don't want to regret throwing
away a good relationship over this PS
I'm so glad you like Manchester we loved
you here I [ __ ] love going to
Manchester I had a great time and I
would love to go to Liverpool and nuke
and uh was it Newcastle I would like to
do more of those cities up there next
time I come over I would love to meet
you and the beautiful Nia in England one
day just so I can shake the hand and
thank you in person for making a post
uni existential crisis so much more
bearable I don't know what that means
haha stay shiny and go [ __ ] yourself um
all right look you've been through a lot
of [ __ ] okay
and you married this guy nine months in
it's not what what he wants is not what
you want and here's the deal okay as
much as you're gonna feel like you're an
[ __ ] for doing this to this guy what
kind of a [ __ ] 45 year-old guy
marries a 20 year old weighs 47 now and
she's 22 yeah but I move and wants to
like knock her up right away and all
that other kind of stuff yeah I mean he
how do you not know that that's coming
yeah I mean she didn't she's young you
know no no no I'm saying how does he
know that this isn't coming oh I don't
know I mean I just feel like he is like
on you know the middle and age he's a
middle aged and so he's freakish not
middle aged she's over the hill I'm so
sick of people saying 47 47 times - come
on artists what is it
94 yeah how many people make it to 94
not a lot like 94 people make 94 yeah
like 35 is middle-aged 35 times 2 is 70
you have to be true to yourself you're
so young you don't want to have kids now
because yeah your life is gonna change
drastically and you haven't had a chance
to even fully you know experience
everything that you want experience
you're you're way too young people of
course have kids at your age but you're
so young so you know you should just be
honest with him about it and just all
wait a couple can't have kids you don't
know if you don't know who you are what
the [ __ ] you're doing you can't have
kids and honestly it's not your fault
that he waited this long to you know be
in a relationship and have kids yep and
sometimes you have to be selfish yes to
get what you want okay that's it okay
you're being a good takes off now he's
still 47 he can meet a [ __ ] 31 year
old that's who he mean he's meeting a
chick in her 30s who's just sweating it
out going what the [ __ ] I need a baby
tomorrow I need to trap a man that's
that's what he's it's it's not your
fault he's drafting this late in life
he's drafting in the later rounds that's
what's left you know that you know the
trap car trap car then he's gonna he's
gonna date he's gonna date the female
version of it they got this [ __ ]
thing out there called the trap car
speaking of racist they drive it in
they drive this car a nice car they
leave it running with the keys on and
they but they only do it in like non
white neighborhoods yeah it's such
[ __ ]
[ __ ] but anyway don't don't have a
baby just to keep this guy because you
will end up you'll love your baby and
you'll end up hating him but you'll
resent your baby because you didn't get
to go to [ __ ] Joshua Tree any
mushrooms and the wood of a [ __ ] you
supposed to do in your early 20s
whatever what a kids do now in the early
twenties yeah you guys are really at
completely different stages in your life
and this is why you know unfortunately
it's not advisable to marry someone who
could literally be your father
so yeah what's another cool bucket of
water like this writer she is sweet and
you know I don't know it sucks you know
what I mean she sounds like she's
genuinely in love with him and it
doesn't want to break up but this is a
pretty big issue this is a little thing
so he's by the time you're ready he's
gonna be dead I'm just kidding he's
gonna be you know even older so it's
just yeah yeah you could like adapt
that's why I think you said what you had
to say I feel like you're overselling it
now I'm quiet did a great job with the
podcast yeah people people no no they're
gonna love you you trashed me two times
you gave me like the trashing of the
Year twice on one [ __ ] podcast that's
cool
I can live with that I always know when
there's something going on with you
I always know there's something going on
with you I don't know what the [ __ ] it
is because I'm always right because I'm
always right
fine you're not you're a [ __ ] mess
you're freaking out about the holidays I
know you are alright that's it that's
the podcast that's the podcast ladies
and gentlemen that is the podcast bill
burr a white male signing off with Nia
Nia Hill a black female alright have a
great couple of days I'll check in on
how about them apples perfect you're
crushing it all right I'll see you